[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal préparé par la rédaction de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 24 janvier tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
plus de 160 mille personnes sont
concernées en france la maladie de
parkinson est la deuxième pathologie
neurodégénérative derrière alzheimer et
dans les yvelines l'association france
parkinson soutien et informe les malades
elle vient d'ouvrir une antenne à
rambouillet nous en parlons avec nos
invités avec notre invité est le début
d'un nouveau rendez vous réguliers dans
le journal deux fois par mois nous vous
faisons découvrir un lieu du patrimoine
des yvelines c'est ce soir direction
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup 200
hectares de collections végétales
vivante aménagé par le roi louis xiv et
puis à la fin de cette édition nous
serons depuis la californie pour le nam
2019 c'est le plus grand salon de
l'industrie musicale la voie du luthier
une entreprise de guyancourt y
participent
elle y présente des enceintes innovantes
c'était pressenti depuis quelques jours
carlos ghosn a démissionné de son poste
de président du groupe renault le pdg
est incarcéré au japon depuis plus de
deux mois pour des soupçons de
malversations financières pour le
remplacer un tandem le conseil
d'administration de la marque au losange
a nommé aujourd'hui le patron de
michelin jean dominique senard comme
président thierry bolloré numéro deux de
renault devient directeur général carlos
ghosn qui s'en va donc après 14 ans à la
tête de renault avec de juteuses
indemnités autour de 25 millions d'euros
plus sa retraite qu'il devrait bientôt
prendre une affaire forcément suivi l
usine de flins sur seine mais aussi au
technocentre de guyancourt qui emploie
onze mille personnes
écoutez la réaction du syndicat cgt sur
le site collectées par nicolas d'ambri
aujourd'hui et surtout la cgt demande
une transparence concernant la
rémunération de l'ensemble des
dirigeants de l'entreprise est également
une transparence dans les décisions et
la stratégie qui émane de leurs
responsabilités que c'était une
situation est difficile à vivre
priorité par les salariés de renault
lui les accusations est aussi difficile
pour l'entreprise c'est purement
scandaleux que c'est aujourd'hui négocié
par hachette qui sera certainement très
doré pour lui est de plus en plus il
touchera une retraite chapeau qui
dépasse 60 mille euros par mois et nous
allons vous proposer prochainement un
reportage avec l'ensemble de ses
syndicats sur ce technocentre renault à
guyancourt
un projet d'envergure à villepreux
l'entrée de la commune devrait être
complètement reconfiguré à l'horizon
2025 250 logements ainsi qu'un grand
parc urbain sont prévues les contours de
ce dossier avec michael medoro et
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'était l'une des grandes annonces de la
cérémonie de voeux de villepreux le
maire de la commune stéphane mirambeau a
évoqué la création d'un nouveau quartier
en entrée de ville le secteur s'étend du
gymnase alain mimoun au lycée sonia
delaunay au total dix neuf mille mètres
carrés vont être aménagés c'est un
projet qui est important parce que c'est
une zone très emblématique c'est une
zone qui est central au niveau de la
ville et nous voulions réellement que ce
soit la vitrine de villepreux quand on
arrive on veut que les gens se dire
c'est ça villepreux et c'est là que j'ai
envie d'habiter
après un an de concertation avec les
habitants le projet prévoit notamment la
création de 250 logements et un grand
parc urbain avec un kiosque un jardin
partagé une aire de jeux pour les
enfants une grande pelouse
donc il y aura un grand parc urbain on
peut l'appeler même le central park de
villepreux et puis autour
il y aura quelques immeubles très
environnementaux très vert aussi et ça
va participer à la facilité de la ville
ça va terminer la ville car ça va être
une zone qui va relier tous les
quartiers entre eux c'est un projet que
nous avons pensé en 2008 on est content
de l'avoir fait aujourd'hui avec tous
les villes provient des études de
faisabilité financière et
environnementale auront lieu cette année
si tous les voyants sont au vert
les travaux devraient débuter à
l'horizon 2020 pour une livraison
définitive prévue en 2025 en 2019
l'année politique sera à marquer par les
européennes ça sera le 26 mai prochain
les français devront choisir leurs
eurodéputés pour siéger au parlement de
strasbourg et de bruxelles un scrutin
peu populaire moins de 43 % de
participation aux dernières européennes
de 2014 pour parler de l'europe le
député modem jean noël barrot organise
un débat dans sa 2ème circonscription
des yvelines
c'est à viroflay salle dunoyer de
ségonzac à partir de 20 heures ce jeudi
soir un rendez-vous en présence de la
députée européenne nathalie griesbeck
président de la commission spéciale sur
le terrorisme et de jean dominique
giuliani à la tête de la fondation
robert schuman
elle était déjà actives sur les yvelines
à versailles saint-germain-en-laye ou
encore mantes-la-jolie l'association
france parkinson ouvre une antenne à
rambouillet pour en parler un invité
yves plantec bonsoir y implante hayal
plantec alors on va commencer cet
entretien en disant bien votre prénom
yann plantec alors vous êtes responsable
de cette antenne sur rambouillet alors
avant de parler de votre arrivée à
rambouillet rappelant que parkinson
touche plus de 160 mille personnes en
france il ya vingt-cinq mille nouveaux
cas détectés chaque année environ c'est
une maladie neurodégénérative comment
agit-elle cette maladie quels sont les
symptômes
alors les symptômes sont d'audi verte de
diverses formes vous avez à peu près 45
symptômes qu'ils sont
recensés dans la maladie de parkinson
les plus connus sont les tremblements
sont la lenteur sont les défauts de la
marche également dû le visage figé et
c'est enfin cesser ses 45 tôt mais je
peux pas tous les lycées c'est
impressionnant et quels sont les
traitements aujourd'hui pour retraités
parc impasse de ne pas une
essentiellement mais il ya des
possibilités également de
l'électrostimulation d'une opération qui
permet de mettre des électrodes au
niveau du cerveau d'accord et c'est un
améliorent la vie du patient vous êtes
vous même atteint de parkinson depuis
2012 comment on vit avec cette maladie
on vit pas très bien c'est comme si on
avait un étranger dans le corps donc
c'est pas c'est pas évident tous les
jours mais on s'y attache et puis on
fait en sorte de vivre le mieux possible
et est ce que la recherche progresse
c'est ce qu'il ya l'espoir qu'un jour
cette maladie soit vaincue et ben on
espère on espère add existe depuis elle
est identifiée depuis près de 400 ans
mais on espère qu'on va trouver enfin la
l'origine de la maladie se sont déjà pas
mal pour pouvoir l'acquérir mais ça fait
d'ailleurs partie des missions de
l'association c'est soutenir la
recherche contre parkinson c'est ça
c'est l'une des missions de france
parkinson exactement quelles sont les
autres missions du coup de l'association
c'est le financement effectivement de la
recherche c'est d'être au plus près des
malades donc via les comités il ya
soixante dix sept comités départementaux
en france aujourd'hui c'est également de
l'aide de l'information auprès des
malades sur les traitements sur les sur
les droits des malades
et puis les proches est également
comment ce qu'il ya aussi un rôle de
pour saisir les pouvoirs publics parler
de cette maladie aux pouvoirs publics
essayer que peut être que les pouvoirs
publics s'en saisissent complètement
notamment durant les pénuries de
médicaments qu'on vit en ce moment on
alerte comme pour les autorités sont
sujets à risque allait bien puis en
compte cette maladie de parkinson par
les pouvoirs publics justement oui on
aimerait qu'elle ne soit un peu plus
mais commence à en prendre conscience et
vous parliez des traitements si les
traitements qui évolue il ya de nouveaux
traitements aujourd'hui peut-être dans
le futur
dans le futur je pense il ya des
expérimentations qui sont en différentes
phases de test et on espère dans deux
ans avoir des nouveaux médicaments en
immunothérapie mais il n'y a rien de
gagné pour l'instant alors le dis je
disais cette association france
parkinson est très actif sur le
territoire des yvelines versailles saint
germain menthe et maintenant rambouillet
pourquoi ouvrir cette antenne c'est
d'avoir une présence dans le sud sud
yvelines exactement exactement c'est à
dire qu'on avait adressé versailles
mantes-la-jolie et et saint germain en
laye il nous manquait des proches des
malades dans sur la commune de
rambouillet pour adresser le sud des
yvelines
et c'est chose faite donc le lancement
élu le 16 janvier dernier et la première
réunion entre malades et proches et donc
aura lieu le 20 février à rambouillet à
la salle foch enfin il ya un vrai besoin
des malades et d'ouvrir cette antenne
on a eu 30 personnes sur les quarante
huit qui ont été adressées donc c'est un
véritable succès vous êtes responsable
de cette antenne on disait tout à
l'heure vous même atteint de la maladie
de parkinson c'est important pour vous
de d'en parler de participer à olemps
cette association très importante c'est
très important parce qu'on en arrive à
se soutenir les uns les autres on
discute de la maladie sans tabou et
c'est très important pour l'équilibré le
comment le bien-être des
des pâtes des pâtes des patients et des
aidants c'est un drôle de sedan
l'association il ya ce rôle
d'accompagnement d'en parler c'est aussi
très efficace complètement complètement
et surtout mettront en place des
activités pour les malades et pour les
aidants qu'est ce que vous allez mettre
en place justement avec cette antenne
mal justement la prochaine réunion vadis
t on voir un certain nombre
d'intervenants vont passer dans la salle
pour expliquer ce que c'est que la gym
douce que ce que le cri qu'on que celle
que tai chi qu'est ce que c'est que le
golf pour les handicapés et c'est donc
tout un tas de de commandes d'activité
et ce sont les malades et les proches
qui vont faire les choix des activités
qui veulent voir naître ce rambouillet
donc il y aura un choix fait dans les
prochaines semaines ce choix d'activités
c'est pourquoi faire ses activités elle
elle aide les malades exactement parce
que les balades ont tendance à se
renfermer sur eux mêmes à rester chez
eux ils ont ils ont peur parfois du
regard des autres donc il faut changer
ses habitudes et le fait de pouvoir
faire des activités comme tout à chacun
c'est important pour eux pour leur
bien-être des activités qu'il y aura
aussi peut-être de la sensibilisation
aux idées autour de la maladie de la
sophrologie yoga à peu particulier
lancé sur mére de la boxe thérapie donc
on imagine un sac de frappe avec marqué
par qui nous sommes dessus des gens se
défouler et ça fait du bien
quels sont les objectifs pour cette
antenne que vous êtes fixé c'est au
minimum avoir les trente personnes qui
sont venues la première fois qu'ils
virent est régulièrement j'espère qu'on
aura une vingtaine de personnes à chaque
ligne et que ça devienne une antenne
importante de ce comité des yvelines qui
a été très actif on désactive fois il ya
plein d'activités ils présentent leurs
activités
mantes-la-jolie sur son saint germain et
but c'est que ces activités soient aussi
organisés sur rambouillet et ce qui est
un besoin en bénévoles vous avez un
besoin de bénévoles pour cette antenne
oui on a besoin de bénévoles oui c'est
important parce que je souhaite pas
toujours là dont il faut il faut comme
il faut mais paul est donc je fais un
appel à bénévoles et d'ailleurs le
l'adresse mail du comité des yvelines
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour
vous contacter comment on vous rejoins
pour sept antennes renvoyant on part
d'abord par nous mène directement je
jouerai copies de tous mes mails et puis
je fais des réponses systématiques donc
n'hésitez pas à me contacter et y'a pas
de soucis vous pouvez donc rejoindre
cette antenne de rambouillet ou soutenir
la recherche le site de france parkinson
avec qui s'est affichée tout au long de
cet entretien merci yann plantec d'avoir
été avec nous je les ai bien dit le
prénom quand la fin de cet entretien
et je rappelle que vous êtes le
responsable de l'antenne de rambouillet
pour l'association france parkinson
c'est l'un des concours phare en
coiffure le style and colour 2019 trophy
est organisé par l'oréal et se déroule
ce dimanche à paris pour le prix school
students une yvelinoise noëlla avait
élèves à chatou qui affrontera d'autres
apprentis mélanie peau qu'elle a
rencontré quelques jours avant les bref
une énième répétition
noëlla avait préparé un chignon une
réalisation d'une heure qu'elle
travaille depuis le mois d'octobre pour
lust in and colour trophy sur son modèle
qui l'accompagnera et sur sept est
malléable
j'aime le challenge j'ai jamais envie de
découvrir autre chose que ce que je fais
a quotidiennement et
je voulais aussi découvrir d'autres
talents et
je me dis je suis capable de pouvoir
remporter ce concours alors je me lance
j'ai réalisé un balayage à une couleur
sur mon modèle j'ai choisi de faire le
chignon parce que j'aime le travail
minutieux c'est très délicat ça demande
du temps sa demande à l'intention et je
voulais faire quelque chose de beau
quelque chose bas de beauregard une
inscription au concours qu'elle doit à
son école le hisser y à chatou
l'établissement propose chaque année à
ses quatre vingts élèves de se présenter
noëlla est la première à atteindre ce
niveau elle s'intéresse à tout c'est à
dire que lé autant technicienne que dans
la coupe
quand je vous dis qu'elle innove c'est
qu'elle vient changer salon et qu'elle
l'est dans un salon qui est un barber
shop donc vraiment rien ne l'arrête elle
extrêmement volontaire pour noël à c'est
une opportunité de l'inscrire sur son cv
d'en parler de serre un bouc et puis
pour l'école va bien sûr
on mettra ça sur nos sites internet sur
nos réseaux sociaux c'est chouette
d'accompagner une élève et qu'elle
arrive à ce niveau là le 27 janvier
noëlla affrontera trois autres apprentis
dans le concours national
la finale internationale se déroulera en
mars à paris
noëlla espère plus tard ouvrir un centre
de beauté et en plus du prix school
students noëlla avait participé
également dans la catégorie choix du
public vous pouvez voter sur elle sur la
page facebook qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
autre concours celui de meilleur ouvrier
de france de l'année dernière 2018 et un
yvelinois et en lice parmi neuf
candidats catégorie art paysage et
sébastien tellier 32 ans est un ancien
élève du chef le centre horticole
d'enseignement et de promotion c'est
d'ailleurs au sein de l'établissement du
tremblay sur mauldre qu'il présente son
jardin qui se nomme terre de voyages 700
heures de travail ont été nécessaires
pour le réaliser
sébastien tellier qui passait
aujourd'hui l'épreuve orale du concours
des mof le jury s'est déplacé dans
l'après-midi les propos sont recueillis
par manon barral d'eau j'avais surtout
envie d'un jardin qui s'entretient 1 100
machines thermiques donc pas de talus et
de tronçonneuses pour tourner avec le
glisser lp/o ligue de protection des
oiseaux
je voulais pas les faire fuir être trop
brillant et j'aime écouter la nature en
même temps de faire l'entretien c'est
pour ça qu'on vient jardiner c'est pour
est dehors pour brûler des voitures
qu'il fallait que ce soit un jardin
qu'ils soient calmes je voulais qu'il y
ait de l'eau du minéral de la peau et du
bourg a qui sont les éléments principaux
cure de la nature et je voulais les
retranscrire en faisant une composition
avec beaucoup de plantes qui viennent
enrichir l'arboretum du lycée et les
résultats seront connus au printemps
d'ici là à 850 bulbes pourront éclore
dans ce jardin terre de voyage
on reste dans la nature avec un nouveau
format dans ce journal toutes les deux
semaines nous vous faisons découvrir un
patrimoine du département direction ce
soir l arboretum de versailles
chèvreloup c'est un parc situé entre le
centre commercial parly 2 et le château
de versailles le regroupe près de 2500
espèces d'arbres le site a été acquis
par louis xiv en 799 et propose
aujourd'hui et des visites le reportage
est signé mickaël landreau
un havre de paix à quelques mètres du
château de versailles bienvenue à
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup ce
vaste parc de 200 hectares au sens 2500
espèces d'arbres venus du monde entier
l'histoire de ce lieu remonte à l'époque
de louis xiv le lien avec le château de
versailles c'est que le domaine de
chèvreloup fait partie du domaine de
versailles
à l'origine le domaine de chèvreloup
était en fait un domaine agricole qui a
été acquis par louis xiv à partir de
1685 et dans le but d'étendre son
territoire de chasse
donc c'était un domaine qui était
cultivé encore par des fermiers dans le
but de fournir des espaces pour le
gibier le site officiellement été
attribué au muséum d'histoire naturelle
en 1922 mais ce n'est que dans les
années 1960 qu'il devient officiellement
un arboretum
le public pourra le visiter pour la
première fois en 1979
aujourd'hui les curieux peuvent observer
l'intégralité du site et y découvrir des
arbres de toutes tailles
c'est bien mais est-ce parce que le
sapin à noël qu'on a classiquement dans
les maisons donc un épicéa abies mais
c'est une variétés horticoles men et
celui ci a maintenant 30 ans du plus
petit au plus grand l'arboretum abrite
plusieurs séquoia américain planté entre
1922 et 1925
c'est l'espèce la plus grosse du monde
cantons contre volume de troncs sont que
des arbres qui peuvent atteindre 95
mètres dans la nature alors ici on a des
arbres qui font simplement une petite
vingtaine trentaine de mètres ils sont
vraiment des petits jeunes parce que ces
désordres qui peut vivre plusieurs
milliers d'années
l'arboretum abrite également depuis 1982
2000 m² de serres le site regroupe 5000
plants et fait partie des quatre plus
grandes structures de ce type en ile de
france
ici on reconstitue des climats tropicaux
sec et aride tempérée ou des jungles
luxuriantes
ils ont toutes les conditions pour
donner le la
leur puissance c'est-à-dire chaleur
humidité et lumière donc à partir de ce
moment là vous avez une explosion une
explosion de la végétation qui est digne
de son nom son biotope d'origine
seuls des petits groupes visiter les
serres chaque mois sur inscription les
plantes sont principalement utilisé pour
les recherches ou pour fournir des sites
parisiens ici cheuvreux luz et 90% des
collections végétales du jardin des
plantes de paris donc il ya constamment
des échanges qui se font des plantes que
l'on met à maturité ici et qu'on envoie
après dans les grandes serres du jardin
des plantes de paris
mais certains trésors sont conservées
précieusement ici c'est le cas de ce
cactus qu'on retrouve seulement
l'amérique centrale et dans la
cordillère des andes
c'est une trappe à la gav qui a en
reflet de un peu gris bleuté un volume
et c'est exceptionnel elle attire l'oeil
d'une façon assez extraordinaire il s'y
plaît aussi à la preuve c'est qu'il a
trouvé sa place y fait il est tout à
fait adapté à notre climat versailles et
sous protection en 2018 l'arboretum de
verseilles chèvreloup a attiré près de
23 mille visiteurs du mois d'avril à
novembre à trésors du patrimoine
libinois encore cachées qui gagne à se
faire connaître mais des enceintes
fabriqué par un passionné de musique
électronique est un artisan production
de la société la voie du luthier créé en
2018 à guyancourt
cette start up est actuellement au namm
c'est le plus grand salon de l'industrie
de la musique qui est se déroule près de
los angeles et qui présente donc sur
place plusieurs enceintes avant de la
retrouver sur place découverte de cette
entreprise avec nicolas landry sang
c'est l'enceinte bluetooth mais en
version lui tiff
comme bill gates et paul allen le
guyancourt toi christophe duquenne et le
vendéen marc lucas ont monté leur
premier prototype chez eux à partir de
aujourd'hui ils ont créé leur société la
voie du luthier avec deux produits londe
et la pyramide
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il fallait des
enceintes amplificateur classique pour
entendre un instrument électronique
aujourd'hui en fait en mon offre une
caisse de résonance naturel en bois
comme une caisse de guitare ou une thèse
de piano pour entendre le son de
l'instrument électronique lorsqu'on va
avoir à l'intérieur on a un petit
amplificateur classe dépendant celui-là
qui fait deux fois 30 watts on prendra
déjà un volume qui relativement
important on a les batteries ayant et
ronald récepteur bluetooth qui est qui
qui va permettre de gérer tout ça
christophe duquenne est passionné de
musique électronique
de son côté marc lucas est artisan
luthier la libration se propage sur
toute cette table d'harmonie qui va
faire vibrer de l'air et l'air va venir
jusqu'à nos oreilles et c'est comme ça
qu'on va entendre le son de l'accord d'
amplifier ou le sont les créateurs qui
va être amplifié cette start up est
composé d'une dizaine de personnes il
collabore avec d'autres sociétés comme à
cannes audio à l'origine de cet
instrument électronique
c'est un instrument et scribd expressif
et continue donc c'est quelque chose qui
est assez novateur aussi
quand on se rend compte que la musique
électro acoustique entre les guitaristes
où les violonistes vont trouver aussi un
gros intérêt sur ce type d'instrument on
sera par exemple à francfort à la
musique mais ça ne va pas être dans la
partie électronique en fait dans la
partie avec les guitares et les violons
elle est donc présenté ses instruments à
d'autres types de musiciens éric lucas
et membre du groupe deep forest
collabore aussi sur ce projet prochaine
étape une vague de livraison prévue en
avril prochain et on retrouve depuis les
etats unis le président de cette
start-up bonsoir christophe duquenne
bonsoir il est 9h 20 où vous êtes vous
et vous participez donc au namm le plus
grand salon de l'industrie musicale qui
se déroule en ce moment tout proche de
los angeles en californie
vous y présenter les enceintes
innovantes que l'on a vu dans ce
reportage pourquoi participer à ce salon
pourquoi y être c'est marrant plus gros
salons du monde actuellement en terme de
promotion de la boîte de luthier c'était
vraiment important pour nous pour ce
lancement que les gens puissent
découvrir ici et on qu'on voit déjà
avant même le débat redémarrage du salon
on va déjà pour plutôt des exposants qui
viennent nous voir
après on a bien eu raison de venir ça
devait être un beau succès
jeudi c'est le plus grand salon de cette
industrie quels sont les interlocuteurs
qui sont présents sur place de notre
côté on a pu échanger avec une
importateur allemand qu'il soit sur son
stand
donc on est sur un stand partager avec
la cage aux folles la voie du métier les
gouttes partout des marques françaises
la grande toile square france est et
quel est le programme sur place puisque
vous avez déjà des rendez-vous de fixer
est ce que le programme est déjà établi
où ça va ça va se décider dans les
prochaines heures
de l'autre côté se définit au fur à
mesure on a déjà rencontré des gens et
hier combien de temps les rangs des
grands yeux on a pas mal de rendez-vous
et des liqueurs et des influenceurs bois
de céné domaine musical et qui vont
venir nous voir des reportages ce qu'on
est en train de jerez et quels sont les
objectifs pour vous c'est vous
développer sur le marché américain
restait sur le marché européen c'est
quoi les objectifs pour vous le bleu n'a
pas vraiment un rayonnement
international
on va toucher aussi bien le japon que
l'europe que les états unis en étant ici
c'est vrai que mandataire qui que
certains financement participatif et on
a un tiers de notre guide starter qui
est sur le marché américain
c'est aussi un marché a choisi donc on
vous répond à l'ensemble des objectifs
accords internationaux et spécifiquement
américain on est aujourd'hui pour pour
percer dans ce domaine de la musique
il faut être présent c'est quoi le plus
gros marché qui existe et ce marché
américain
le marché américain est important mais
il y en a d'autres le marché américain
les plus prodigues des petites boîtes en
week-end sera marché de niche encore sur
ce qu'on fait on a vraiment besoin de
l'international beaucoup vous pas rester
spécifiquement américain spécifiquement
français d'aller sur l'ensemble de
l'année sera marquée consulat qui après
moi un rayonnement international et ce
qui ferait pour vous que ce soit une
réussite cette participation au namm
nucléaire bon indicateur c'est le nom de
youtube heures que vous me dire qu'ils
vont faire des vidéos reportages
est ce qu'on aura derrière ses bras sa
coiffure l impact qu on a après il peut
y avoir des partenariats commerciaux
techniques ça généralement ça prend
beaucoup de temps donc je servais des
contacts avec la ville et ya travaillé
et bien vous souhaite un bon salon merci
à christophe duquenne d'avoir été avec
tous je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la voie du luthier vous
participez donc en ce moment même au
namm à los angeles près de los angeles
c'est le plus gros salon de l'industrie
musicale
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
l'édition complète et ses reportages est
à retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 dans un
instant le retour du 7-8 loisirs avec
marylène yapi chinois et parlera
notamment du sport féminin à l'occasion
d'une journée qui se déroule aujourd'hui
c'est la journée internationale du sport
féminin et belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]